how did you get pink zone into your
first film festival so pings and high
rates were premiere at the density Film
Festival which truly is amazing festival
which is one of the biggest indie film
festival in LA and we had this other
work we had the world premiere to change
theatre so it was such a great moment
and the people there the founders of the
festival elastics Callen and Michael
Trent are just too amazing film lovers
and they are some of the greatest people
I met so far in this business they are
remaking and they managed to create this
vessel which get even bigger and bigger
with the time and still maintained its
connection with filmmakers and the
audience so so from me the choice of
going with them and when I received
their notification that they wanted to
have to screen the movie to be part of
the official selection I was like of
course we want to go with you because
they had this great spirit about them
there is this great spirit about them
and they love movies and they make you
feel like it so it's great so the other
festivals that you've chosen to submit
how did you choose them and do you ever
ask them to waive fees and I mean it's a
lot yeah it is a lot and I I know some
people are seen to waive fees I
personally especially at the beginning
of the first of all circuit I was not
being comfortable with asking like oh do
this for free to me because I understand
that especially if you are into indie
filmmaking you can understand and relate
to independent festivals and the way I
mean they need to make a living and to
to show you even more movies they need
to have this phone so for me paying the
fees even though sometimes it can be
brutal because it
kind of expensive when you're doing a
lot of them you are participating to
something which is helping you at the
end of the day epping your film so so so
I chose and way I chose these festivals
is I new dances with films type of films
they were screening it was perfectly to
right target for for Pink Zone same
thing for action of him which is more of
a genre of film festival and now we have
so many I mean at the same time as we
chose this one we just learned that we
got into a fender Sporto which is one of
the greatest general film festival in
Europe and who basically screening the
top third genre films in in in the world
and we got in because they trust they
have this way of doing things where they
show the must talk about general movies
of the year at the same time as they
take leap of faith for small genre films
like us and so the each film will find
its own home and of course not every
festivals are for every film of course
you have to know which you made you have
to know what is going to be your
audience and once you know that you can
target precisely the kind of festivals
you want to go into
you